Justin Bieber lives it up in London with
Rihanna work hard play hard both singers
enjoyed a night out on the town Friday
hitting up London's tape nightclub for
some fun ahead of their headlining sets
at the V Music Festival RiRi looked sexy
in a low-cut denim ensemble while Justin
kept a casual in a white t-shirt and
ripped jeans but all eyes were on the
blonde beauty he left the club with
model Bronte plan PA the pair continued
their fun weekend together on Sunday
here they are boarding a private
helicopter together but according to
Bronte's instagram it's not the first
time the duo has hung out here's a group
shot she posted earlier this month the
Biebs front and center relaxing on a
pool floats
Oh
meanwhile back in LA is Justin's rumored
gal pals Sofia Richie the 17 year old
younger sister of Nicole Richie was
romantically linked to the singer after
they recently spent time together and
shared photos on social media I'm just
posting what I really like what do you
think is just in dating Sophia Bronte or
is he just single and having fun let us
know on twitter at ET now
you